oh i'll be 100 honest with you guys
right now as i always am but this is a
hogwarts legacy video i've really tried
to avoid making at this point though i
feel like it has to be done i think it's
time i really do that we all have to ask
ourselves the question is this game in
trouble look another big gaming event
but yet more disappointment for hogwarts
legacy fans i truly thought it was going
to be there guys i really did and for
those of you who follow me on twitter
and follow this channel i try not to
hype up these events too much but it
really felt like the stars were aligning
on this one you've got the fact that the
game was initially unveiled at the ps5
showcase almost a year ago to the day of
this year's playstation event we get
absolutely nothing on the game this year
except for the delay of course and then
seemingly out of nowhere hogwarts legacy
pops up in a sizzle trailer that
playstation tweeted out just weeks
before the showcase event now the
showcase event has come and gone and we
still have absolutely nothing new on
hogwarts legacy social media is quiet
nothing for playstation absolutely
nothing so will we see more of the game
at all in 2021 what does this mean for
the ultimate release date and the
question we all want to know but are
afraid to ask is the development in
trouble now like i said in the beginning
i gotta be real i gotta be honest with
you guys i normally i try to keep things
very positive here i really do but at
the same time i don't want to sugarcoat
things and make you guys think that
everything is 100 fine when deep down
i'm thinking maybe it's not so fine now
i also want to stress i'm recording this
the night of the playstation showcase
event so emotions are still fresh
they're still raw hopefully after a
couple of days i'll calm down and be
able to look at things in better
perspective but this video represents my
true feelings here in the moment right
after this event happened and make sure
you stick around toward the end of the
video i'm going to talk about some of my
concerns and some signs that i have
noticed that make it completely logical
for someone to be concerned about the
development of this game and since it
definitely looks like we're gonna have
quite a bit of time on our hands before
hogwarts legacy comes out now might be a
great time to revisit the harry potter
books and he can actually check out one
of the seven harry potter audio books
for free thanks to today's sponsor
audible.com just look for my audible
affiliate link down in the description
box below where you can activate a free
30-day trial of audible now here's the
cool thing about this guys even if you
cancel within that 30-day period you
still get to keep the free title that
you redeemed even after you've canceled
even better if you're an amazon prime
member you're actually going to get two
free audiobooks so you can get two of
the seven harry potter books as they are
all available on amazon.com i actually
did this a few years ago to redeem a
couple of harry potter books and jim
dale just does an absolutely phenomenal
job on the american versions so when it
comes to will we see more of the game in
2021 let's try and take a step back and
think logically about this there's
really only one more big gaming event
this year and that's the game awards
with jeff keely yes i know we still have
the tokyo game show and while harry
potter is certainly a worldwide brand i
would be incredibly shocked to see
anything new from hogwarts legacy at tgs
i just don't think it's the right
setting don't think it's the right
environment for it it could happen but i
would be incredibly shocked i gotta say
initially long before we knew anything
about the timing of this year's
playstation showcase i had originally
guessed the game awards would be a
logical place where we might finally see
an update on hogwarts legacy likely in
the form of a new trailer but as time
went on it really became clear to me
that it is highly likely sony has some
sort of marketing deal for hogwarts
legacy so i thought hey the playstation
showcase that event is gonna make much
more sense so yeah i do still think it's
possible we could see something at the
game awards it's not like they couldn't
show it there even if sony does have the
marketing for it i just don't personally
expect it to be there now again trying
to look on the bright side of things it
is also entirely possible sony or wb
could drop a trailer for the game at any
point it doesn't necessarily have to be
at a big event the hogwarts legacy
trailer is one of the most viewed videos
on the entire youtube page for
playstation just just think about that
for a second of course the harry potter
ip itself is still huge they could
totally get away with dropping a trailer
anytime they want but when you consider
that sony doesn't really do other shows
anymore like e3 or gamescom this very
well could have been our last chance to
see an update on the game before next
year's playstation showcase again they
could totally drop it on its own but i
certainly think it helps to drop it
during a big event like this so you get
even more eyeballs on it if you think
about a lot of the third-party games
that they showed this year quite a few
of those are releasing over the next
several months so if hogwarts legacy
ends up being a holiday 2022 game then
it would be the perfect time to show it
at next year's playstation showcase i
know it just seems so incredibly far
away guys trust me i'm right there with
you january this year is when we found
out about the delay when we thought the
game was coming out i mean we thought we
would have the game in our hands this
year then january hits and they delay it
all the way to 2022 and then absolutely
nothing now this is just me personally
talking here i do not think they should
go
that long all the way to next year's
playstation showcase without marketing
the game or providing some sort of
update we know they were hiring a
community manager so hopefully once that
person is fully in place we'll start to
get updates again i want to reiterate
that we're not talking about rushing
avalanche here anytime i talk about
wanting updates or progress reports on
the game a lot of folks in the comments
start talking about how don't rush
avalanche we want them to take all the
time they need and i completely agree we
do not want to rush avalanche but
marketing and promoting the game is
completely separate from that there are
plenty of things they can do in the
lead-up to the game to keep fans
informed and confident that this game is
progressing along nicely it doesn't
always have to be some epic new trailer
as far as the release date goes to me
i'm just going ahead now and expecting
holiday 2022. i actually thought even
going into the playstation showcase this
year i kind of thought holiday 2022
seemed like the most likely time but
given that it had been so long since we
heard anything at all then we had that
little sizzle trailer that dropped where
hogwarts legacy appeared i thought man
this is it for sure it's going to be
there but even with that i was still
kind of thinking late 2022. we all know
the game was originally slated for 2021
so when that initial delay happened i
think many were kind of hoping okay
maybe it'll be early 2022 and to be fair
i guess that is still technically
possible but we are quickly running out
of days here in 2021 where they could
have enough lead time you know to build
up a marketing campaign if that were
indeed the case of like a february march
release date given the fact that the
game was delayed so early in 2021 the
numerous hires we've seen posted to work
on the game even now today someone
tweeted at me a link where they are
still hiring to work on this game
combine all that with the total silence
that we've seen from all the official
hogwarts channels no tweets
just just nothing like completely dark
remember it took that tweet from the
warner media ceo jason kolar for us to
get any little tiny nugget of
information so again to be totally real
with you guys here i think it's
completely fair if you are concerned
about the game's development right now
i'll just go ahead and say it i myself
am concerned about the game's
development avalanche is taking on a
project bigger than anything they've
ever done i'm certainly willing to give
them a chance and have high hopes for
what they can do but i'm concerned again
just have to be upfront and honest with
you guys here as great as that trailer
looked overall if we were really going
to get nitpicky there were spots in
there where the graphics look kind of
rough the frame rate looks a little
rough so just all these things combining
together
it is a lot of concern for me now could
everything be completely totally fine
and development progressing along nicely
absolutely but then to me as a fan i'm
left to say well why are things so quiet
why aren't devs talking why are they
taking down the interview that one of
the devs did on a youtube channel that
wasn't even mainly about hogwarts legacy
he just talked a little bit about
hogwarts legacy stuff like that gets
taken down and then you have the whole
warner media situation which i already
made a whole separate video on this and
the further that hogwarts legacy gets
pushed back then the more of a chance
that that big sale that that merger of
warner and discovery will actually have
somewhat of an impact on hogwarts legacy
again potentially we can certainly still
hold out hope that we'll see something
new on the game before year's end maybe
at the game awards or maybe they just
dropped something on their social media
i don't know let me know what you guys
think in the comments below i know we're
all disappointed that it wasn't there
but are you guys still confident in the
game's development if not what are your
concerns as always thank you all so much
for watching i'll talk to you again soon